the gyro can experience was that was
that the case with the cantina scene in
Star Wars because the Star Wars scene
there's that's that's a crazy scene
because you've got so many characters in
that scene and today when you go back
and look at it like it's pretty cheesy
yeah yeah yeah well I that came about
originally the you know film was done in
England nobody knew Star Wars was gonna
be Star Wars you know Stuart Freeborn
was the makeup artist in the film he did
the Wookiee he did the cantina scene
originally but George wanted to
embellish on it and didn't like all of
the stuff that he did so at ILM which
was in van nuys then Industrial Light
magic when I first started the guys who
were doing the visual effects were for
that for Star Wars my friends that I met
at Chloe's Dennis Muren and Ken Ralston
were shooting the special effects and
George came in and said do you know
anybody they can make a mask because I
knew I want to add some masks to them to
the cantina scene and they go yeah we do
so they called me and so I went over to
Valjean Avenue and George on a flatbed
editor showed me the sequence as it
existed and I was flipping out let me
say what a cool idea to have this bar
full of aliens you know and go on let's
do let's do it you do one it has suck
you know like that's kind of like the
alien pirate that's got a like alien
parrot character and there's nothing
goes well we don't have any money you
know it's like you know we've already
spent the money you know we don't have a
lot of money for this I just want masks
you know and I said well I you know what
I have a bunch of stuff I made myself
for fun that we can throw in there that
there's a devil guy that money that I
made that five years before Star Wars
you know there's a werewolf guy in
another yeah I would Chloe eyes I made
those before Star Wars I just said you
can use them I thought they were gonna
be stuck in the background you know and
but we did like the cantina band you
know the first stop yeah the first
aliens that you see almost all the first
days you see our lawns that we did I
think we did 30 and but what was great
is yeah that was one of the masks I made
before he's good Jamie's the best yeah
that Jamie yeah that was such a great
scene too though you know these are
Stuart freeborn's things you know but
the thing that's great
Tina ban was never there and when you
see the movie you think it's there and
I've uses so many times where I say can
we shoot this like in post-production
that's the devil guy yeah and these guys
were the guys that we when the guys in
this other guy's week so you shot the
alien band and post yeah in in Los
Angeles in a by different people at a
different time and I've said to you know
I want to say to people let's can we
shoot this in post and because what
happens you know most directors don't
like dealing with this yet you know and
they'll put it off to the last shot of
the day and then it's like well you got
45 minutes in and go but this is the
money shot right and I prepared four
months for this and you're giving me 45
minutes to do this it's not right you
know let's shoot it in post-production
well that'll never work I'll never match
it's like did you see Star Wars yeah you
know the bandits in the cantina yeah
that was shot by different people in a
different country months later did you
know that no no it's like you think
they're there you hear the music that
they're playing through the scene you
know these are some of our aliens those
two guys the blue guys as is that
werewolf and then that was the only one
that looked like a mask well yeah I mean
I think it's I think they all look like
mess we made that guy and that mask in
the background was one of mine that I
had before too you know
but yeah great scene again it was a
great idea and people I did not make
that one that was on Stewarts um people
think of it fondly you know and it's
more that it's a great ideas and the
work is great yeah what was it was a
great conglomeration of cool characters
all in one bar and you know at the time
it was completely in unique and new
things oh yeah and but after that every
movie every space movie had a cantina
scene you know and it's like American
world do every transformation after
American world was basically the same
transformation oh they did the same
things you know
[Applause]